the radical left is quaking in their
boots because when an African-American
conservative who believes in the future
of this nation stands up to be counted
they push back that's a good sign we're
on the right message so I guess he's
saying the left is scared of him because
he's black which is a really strange
thing to say now that being said is he
going to run an identity campaign and
what I mean by that is Nikki Haley the
only things she really was willing to
draw a distinction with Trump on
seem to be that she's a woman and she's
younger and she's a person of color
maybe Tim Scott's plan is the same which
is I'm younger and I'm black I don't
know the problem is there's no evidence
that the Maga Republican party is
looking for a black candidate and I've
already explained to you why that is and
and that's gone back for a while so not
exactly a winning proposition